hey what's going on everybody my channel
got deleted this morning
this channel if you're watching right
now obviously there's good news up front
we're back means that i won't be
exclusively uploading to the digital
freedom platform like i thought i would
but i still wanted to talk about sort of
what happened and explain to you guys
uh what's going on because many of you
guys asked me what happened either you
saw my channel was deleted or you missed
it entirely go
give me tell me what happened did brian
take it down did dan lok take it down
sadly it's even dumber than you can ever
imagine but before we get into the story
though let me just say this if this
has taught me anything having my channel
just deleted
overnight literally it's that i have to
diversify platforms so i never
ask you guys but if you wouldn't mind
following me on twitter and or
instagram i use them occasionally but
more than anything it would just help me
if i had access to you guys on multiple
platforms because as stupid as as it is
for me to have to do like a call to
action like this
this has taught me that i can't just
rely on youtube it's in fact it's stupid
to rely
on youtube and it makes it you know
hugely risky just to give me a better
way to contact you guys if this happens
again
because it very well could it's just a
matter of youtube literally just
snapping their fingers one day and i'm
gone some bot somewhere
so pitch over okay um now i can tell you
guys the story
starts at 5 45 a.m straight up i'm
asleep
i get two emails from youtube that i
wake up to now bear in mind i never get
emails from youtube so i'm excited i'm
thinking maybe they're gonna give me
some award
what am i gonna get well the first one's
a community guideline strike
my first ever okay and if you guys don't
know community guidelines strikes it's
what we all agree to
or the guidelines are what we agreed to
when we join the website strike is what
you get when you violate
those guidelines right and if you get
too many strikes three strikes
specifically and then a warning
your your whole channel is deleted okay
so you start with a warning before they
start accumulating the strikes and then
you get three strikes
and your channel gets deleted i've never
even had a warning before this is my
first ever thing so
i wake up to this and i'm thinking that
sucks i wonder what it is but no big
deal right like
i'm fine just one guideline strike i've
got three more to go
but then i get i check out the next
email i'm thinking you know what is this
now
now maybe i'm getting my award for free
speech from youtube
no uh it's another email saying that my
whole channel
has been deleted they say quote we have
reviewed your content and found
severe or repeated violations of our
community guidelines it's gone
your channel's gone because of this
we've removed your channel
from youtube out of nowhere poof gone
thanos snapped out of existence i mean
what video could have possibly been
responsible for this
youtube must have carefully considered
my content for just
snapping me out of existence right they
must have had a good reason
let's check it out oh boy it's the
dogecoin video
that's right guys the channel that is
threatening youtube
is the truth about dogecoin where i made
some shocking
claims in their role it and if you are
someone who's still a fan of dogecoin i
think that's fine
if you look at it for what it is which
is gambling right
a lot of these coins they're just like
big plays
that probably will die off very soon and
if you know you're investing in
something
that's gonna fall apart i guess do what
you want with your money right
telling people to be responsible with
their money and not to go
into the hype and to be careful that'll
get you deleted from the platform
i can't believe it dude dogecoin did me
in i thought it would be something more
exciting i thought it would be
brian rose coming after me some other
big guru some
no it's just talking about a meme coin
worth like 10 cents
that'll take you out that's you're done
you're a danger you're a threat to
society
telling people not to invest in it it's
the least controversial video i think
i've ever done
dude that's always the way it works with
me it's like the less controversial
i go the more i get in trouble for some
reason
so i wake up to this i'm like not even
brushed to my teeth i haven't had my
coffee yet
and it's like yeah your whole livelihood
is gone so i complain on twitter i
appeal it
and within like a few hours oh they go
they
tell me no we made a mistake have your
channel back we're going to give it to
you and we're going to reverse this
strike
and so even the dogecoin video you can
watch it right now on my channel to see
what could have possibly caused such a
ruckus
for youtube so now i'm back but i'm
confused because i thought you had to
have
three strikes to get your channel
deleted i only had one
channel's gone and like i guess i'm
grateful that they let me back on the
platform
that they realized this what this was
but i'm only grateful in the way you
can be grateful to for somebody stopping
doing something that they shouldn't have
been doing in the first place it's like
a real
toxic relationship kind of thing it's
like yeah thanks for not being a jerk
anymore i don't know here's a crazy idea
maybe it shouldn't be possible for you
to have never gotten
a warning in your life from youtube and
then one day wake up and your whole
channel is deleted
it's just impossible to feel valued by a
platform that just
overnight deletes your channel and then
goes oh actually we're kind of fine with
you can come back
it's so frustrating man i don't know how
this could happen and what's crazy about
it is i'm almost positive it was a bot
that did it because look look at the
facts they email me at 5 45
two emails right in a row it's the same
minute that those emails went out it's
like automated so it's like hey
we removed one video and then hey oh by
by the way we decided the video was so
bad that we deleted your whole channel
so it wasn't a human doing this this is
literally a bot looking at my thing and
going yeah this can't be on our platform
i don't know how you can allow imperfect
algorithms to do this
to literally take away someone's
livelihood it's insane uh and i know no
human could have reasonably watched that
video because
nothing in that video even gets close is
even in the same stratosphere
as what they accused me of which is to
be clear violating their harmful
and dangerous policies so that's
basically the story in a nutshell and
i'm not trying to complain too much
because
youtube is great for a lot of things and
being a youtuber is pretty awesome so
i'm not
asking i'm not you know wiping my tears
with
dollar bills over here just like oh you
know like
feel bad for me no i have it pretty
sweet everyone who's on youtube has it
pretty sweet
but the bad part of this job is that you
just have
zero job security you could wake up
overnight
have your whole channel deleted even if
you followed all the rules whether it be
demonetization an
algorithm change or what happened to me
a bot just zapping my channel
you're one youtube mistake away from
being gone
like it's that's the part of this job
that sucks
this guy brandon on twitter says it best
he goes
imagine any other place of work doing
this just texting you at 5am to fire you
and you gotta beg for your job back
and they're like oh yeah our bad here's
your livelihood back
that's pretty accurate for how it feels
right now
all i can really say is i am glad to be
back
i'm happy to be making videos for you
guys and it makes me even more grateful
for what i get to do but if you guys
don't mind i mean again
again please follow me on twitter and
instagram it really helps me keep track
of you
i don't just want to lose everything
that we've built together thanks to
the community for sticking up for me a
lot of people on youtube including
roberto blake patty galloway uh james
johnny
david fuller so many people came to
support me and even more people that i'm
not even mentioning right now
and i'm grateful for that and uh yeah i
mean here's hoping it doesn't happen
again
either way guys i'll be back tomorrow
hopefully with another video
appreciate y'all see you next
this ain't time it seems nothing but a
trick trying to sell me on a dream but
that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee